elsewhere in the Middle East a political
fate of Israel's long serving Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu is uncertain
this morning elections ended in an
apparent tie between Netanyahu's party
and that of his main challenger Seth
Doane is in Tel Aviv for us Seth what
happens now at this point it is just too
close to call now voting here is just
the first step of this process now that
backroom deal making begins and that's
where really all of this fell apart the
last time this is not the outcome that
printed that Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu would have liked to have seen
now we're seeing some scrambling to try
to create a coalition government that
could see political foes join forces
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
campaigned both times on his close
relationship with President Trump and
with America and touted some of these
major foreign policy wins like the u.s.
moving its embassy to Jerusalem when
other complicating factor in all of this
one other question is the Trump
administration's proposal for Mideast
peace it is not clear how the outcome of
the election might affect that or
possibly further delay the rollout of
that possible peace plan now this is not
just about the political future of
Netanyahu he is also facing corruption
charges and Anthony he would like to
create a parliament that would protect
him Seth Doane in Israel thank you Seth